TUESDAY AUGUST TWENTIETH MEETING
OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING.
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE --
WE KNOW ENOUGH MEMBERS TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
WOULD.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A TWO ITEMS
THIS MORNING OF THE FIRST FILE
ITEM. ONE AJ ARE FORTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
ANOTHER BURDENS ON MILLIONS OF
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND SENIORS
ASSISTANCE THROUGH HEAD.
OF THIS AT A TIME WHEN WE SHOULD
BE PROVIDING MORE ASSISTANCE TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE BECAUSE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT PEOPLE ARE
THEIR MOST PROSPEROUS WHEN THEY
HAVE HOUSING AND MAKES SENSE.
HR FORTY THREE CALLS UPON THE
PRESIDENT AND THE SECRETARY OF
HUD TO HONOR THEIR PLEDGES TO
PROTECT.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO
VETO ANY LEGISLATION THAT
UNDERMINES THESE PROGRAMS AND TO
WORK WITH CONGRESS TO FURTHER
PROTECT RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS AND THE MISSION OF HUD.
I THANK YOU AN ASTEROID VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WIN
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S MEGHAN ROSE I'M OF
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
OF AFFORDABLE SENIOR HOUSING --
ABOUT HALF A MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE SOME TYPE OF
HAD RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS COULD RAISE
THEIR RENTS ON AVERAGE 220%.
OUT ANNUALLY AND SO WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS MEASURE AND
HOPE THAT THIS WILL INFLUENCE
OUR CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS TO
OPPOSE THESE REFORMS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER.
OF MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
OF THIS [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE.
OKAY OF ANY FINAL COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY TIME THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
I NOW [inaudible]
SHOWING [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GLORIA I MOM [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
WE YOU WILL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AND OUR SECOND FINAL ITEM IS S.
B. SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SENATOR
WIENER WELCOME.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF ARE FOR
WORKING WITH US IS BILL OF
COURSE THIS IS OUR SECOND TRIP
TO THIS COMMITTEE AT THE LAST
HEARING.
OF THE BILL MOVE FORWARD --
AT SOME ITEMS REMOVED IN ORDER
TO HAVE THE ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE
IN.
A SINCE THEN OVER THE SUMMER.
OF WE WORKED WITH YOU IN YOUR
STAFF ON THIS WAS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN THE CITY IN THE BOTH
HOUSES AND A NUMBER OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS --
AND I THINK WE NOW HAVE A REALLY
EXCELLENT --
BILL AND WE WORKED THROUGH A LOT
OF ISSUES AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
WITH WHERE WE ARE --
AND THE LION'S SHARE OF THE
OPPOSITION.
OF THIS BILL IS OUR FOLLOW UP
LEGISLATION THE SENATE BILL
THIRTY FIVE ON HOUSING
STREAMLINING GO THAT I AUTHORED
LAST YEAR --
CLAIRE MAIN CLARIFICATIONS --
JUST CLEAN UP AND CLARIFICATION
--
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
A BILL DOES --
AMONG THEM ARE CLARIFYING THAT
WEAVERS FROM PARKING
REQUIREMENTS APPLY.
ONLY TO AUTOMOBILE PARKING --
THAT SEAT WAS NOT APPLY TO
CONTRACTUAL NAM LEASE OR FINANCE
AGREEMENTS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
OR EMERGENCY HOMELESS SHELTERS.
THAT SUBDIVISION APPLICATIONS
ARE HELD TO THE SAME STANDARDS
AND TIMELINES AS THE REST OF THE
PROJECT.
BUT THE DEFINITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE RENTS --
SHOULD CONFORM WITH EXISTING
STATE LAW ON SEVERAL OTHER
MISCELLANEOUS PROVISIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF OF CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
SENATOR WIENER AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AYE WE
BELIEVE SB SEVEN SIXTY FIVE IS.
ADDITIONAL PROGRESS TOWARDS BY
ON THE SCHOOLS AND FOR AS THE
ROLL OUR EYES TO EFFECTIVELY
UTILIZE STATE RESOURCES TO
TACKLE THIS CRISIS SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THINKING.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
ENGAGING WITH THE MY OFFICE I
WANNA THANK YOUR STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALL THE VARIOUS
PARTS OF GOVERNMENT THAT ENGAGE
WITH US I KNOW THERE'S SOME
PROVISIONS.
ONE THIS MEASURE WAS FIRST IN
FRONT OF US --
THAT -- SOME
WOULD SAY NEEDED A LITTLE BIT
MORE FINE TUNING AND AND I THINK
THROUGH THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK
TOGETHER AND I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT WE'RE IN A
MUCH BETTER.
STRONG BILL ONE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD AND WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT S. B. THIRTY FIVE IS --
IS WORKING --
FOR OUR HOUSING CRISIS TO BE
ADDRESSED SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND WITHOUT BACK TO THE SENATOR
FUELING FINAL COMMENTS.
REQUEST FROM AYE VOTE GREAT
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION BILL PASSED CHU.
CHU AYE MAIENSCHEIN CHAU
[inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE IMAN
WOULD [inaudible]
WHICH I WE WILL WAIT FOR AT ON
MEMBERS BUT YOUR BILL SHOULD BE
OUT.
THANK YOU CENTER.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA WAIT.
FOR OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO TO GET HERE BUT
UNTIL THEN I WANT TO THANK THE
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR SERVICE --
WE MAY LIKELY HAVE ONE MORE
MEETING OF THE COMMITTEE BEFORE
THE OF THE WEEK BUT WILL
CERTAINLY SURPRISE YOU AS TO
WHEN THAT WILL BE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THE FUN NEVER ENDS
[inaudible]
AND THAT'S THIS MATTER
.
BUT MAYBE.
SINCE WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
BEFORE [inaudible]
THE END [inaudible]
FULLY FEDERAL.
I THINK IT TONIGHT.
THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR.
BUT THERE'S PROBABLY SIMPLY
[inaudible]
MINOR
--
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMO.
J. R. FORTY THREE AYE THE MOTION
USED TO IT. TO BE ADOPTED AYE
AYE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMAN I ITEM NUMBER --
TWO AS I AM SENATE BILL OF SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE OF THE MOTIONS TO
PASS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND
[inaudible]
NINE FORTY THANK YOU
.
NNOVA BANKS THEIR WEIGHT ON
NOBODY --
N'T
.
JUDICIARY TERMS OF THEY SHOWN.
THAT DON'T FALL [inaudible]
YEAH.
SAT OUT KIDS IT IS.
MORE COMMONLY.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE AJ ARE FORTY
CITY ITEM NUMBER --
ONE BE ADOPTED.
BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S FOUR TO ONE
CHAU AYE [inaudible]
SHALL I AND SENATE SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE A MOTION DO
PASS -- ARE
VOTE AT THE MOMENTS.
FOR TWO ZERO ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO
I THANK YOU SIR
.
YEAH OF AMERICA [inaudible]
HUESO.
THIS ONE FIVE DOUBLE
[inaudible]
DJ ARE [inaudible]
CLEARLY.
I READ IT.
OF ITEM NUMBER ONE A. J. R.
THREE DO PASS.
AND AYE THE MOTION IS EVAN THE
VOTES RIGHT NOW ARE [inaudible]
FIVE TO ONE MAIENSCHEIN I ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL SEVEN SIX
FIVE MOTION TO PASS THE VOTE IS.
FIVE TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY MAY
CHIANG I
SO THE FINAL VOTES FOR
FILE ITEM ONE HR FORTY THREE SIX
ONE THAT MEASURES OUT AND FOR
FILE ITEM TO SB.
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE OF THAT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO AND THAT MEASURES ALSO
OUT AND WITH THAT WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED